holy crap that was a lot of information
so we're getting a battlefield 2042 this
year that makes some pretty massive
changes to the series like attachments
that can be swapped on the fly
a revamped class system freaking
tornadoes and some returning mechanics
to the series like ai matches
oh and there's no single player campaign
so we went to a press conference right
before this reveal trailer and we are
able to point out a lot of the details
that you might have missed
hit that thumbs up and subscribe so you
don't miss announcements for alphas
betas and everything leading up to
launch on october 22nd
alright let's get into it okay so
immediately this looks like a conceptual
trailer and not
actual in-game footage that's coming
later but most everything you're about
to see
appears to be in-game and a lot of it
was covered in the official press event
this first shot for example is the
breakaway map which takes place in
antarctica
it's the biggest map of the game around
5.9 kilometers squared
and has areas with huge drops inspired
by damavan peak it's many times larger
than el alamein from battlefield 1942.
overall most of the maps in 2042 are
generally larger than previous
battlefield games
here we immediately see an osprey
aircraft which is a combination of a
plane and helicopter
and finally confirmed this is the
outlook objective on the map which is
mostly accessed by air
on this landing pad we see a specialist
one of 10
that replaces traditional classes since
all the other soldiers around them look
the same
they're probably ai squad mates you can
play with an ai squad
or friends in full ai matches this map
is dotted with these kinds of silos that
can be destroyed
and the osprey crashes into one of them
showing some environmental destruction
before the specialist gets thrown off a
cliff you'll notice next that everyone
except for them pops a parachute and
they use a piece of gear which is a
wingsuit that's in the game
specialists have one ability and one
trait but the rest of their gear is
completely interchangeable we're not
sure yet if you equip a wingsuit or if
it's tied to a specific character
[Applause]
this next map is called kaleidoscope and
takes place in south korea it has
buildings with multiple floors and
canals for amphibious vehicles
you can get to the top of most of these
buildings although devs didn't fully
answer if some of them are out of bounds
you can also use zip lines like the
fantastic downtown la map from hardline
one thing we didn't see in the
presentation and probably is not in the
game
is fully destructible cities that was a
big rumor leading into this
instead there are extreme weather events
like tornadoes which you'll see in a bit
next is a robot dog which is probably
the gadget of boris a specialist closely
resembling the classic engineer of
battlefield he carries an sg36 sentry
system that can be manually controlled
or set to auto target
if this is not an upgraded version of
that then it's one of the many vehicles
or items that you can call in from
airdrops
players can call in parachute drops
anywhere on the map up to full-size
vehicles
which means yay no more getting stranded
this is the discard map in
india which consists of stranded ships
one of which contains a rogue nuclear
sub
inside of that ship which is called
colossus is a close quarters fighting
area we see tanks that look a lot like
merkavas rushing up the field but if
you're an armor expert help us out here
the next gen console and pc versions of
the game will have a 128 players so
there's probably going to be larger
columns of armor than previous
battlefields
a really cool detail here is when this
tank gets hit there's an ammo cook-off
inside instead of the classic hollywood
explosion
that's where ammo inside the tank
detonates next there's what looks like a
levolution event
levolution is back in 2042 still with
the same terrible name
the ship hiding the submarine here is
probably the thing that just opened up
the manifest map located in singapore is
next and this map has something i've
always wanted to see in multiplayer
shooters
moving layouts the containers here are
automatically shifted by a series of
giant cranes as you play
you should know how large maps are in
2042 even this map is larger than
caspian border
moving on to soldiers this guy right
here has a noticeable blue rope on his
back that's because the grappling gun is
in this game
this could be the specialist named
webster who focuses on mobility and is
the closest thing to the old assault
class
something very dark to talk about here
are the people you play as in 2042
are soldiers without nations they just
get hired and then thrown into the meat
grinder by superpowers
there's no campaign so the story will
somehow be conveyed through these fully
voiced specialists
in multiplayer and evolve through the
live service seasons
the yellow armband in this scene could
very well be cosmetic there are four
battle passes so far with premium
versions of each that allow players to
earn
you know special skins and stuff you
find in a regular battle pass
some of the clothing items here also
appear to show player rank oh
and in classic fashion this player gets
their tag stolen this is something you
could do in battlefield 3 and you got to
keep a trophy menu
wall of sorts of tags that you took off
other people the guy taking the tags
espinoza is a specialist that we haven't
seen yet but they have an ability that
gets hinted at later
shot ends with what looks like a
levolution explosion
here we're back on the iceberg section
of the large breakaway map in an area
called the resource depot this is where
large vehicle fights happen
here you can see a hovercraft and what
looks like a ripsaw ev2
luxury tank fighting it out and here we
have some penguins
no idea if that's in the game or part of
environmental destruction
jump to the orbital map in french guiana
players will be fighting over launch
pads and a failed rocket launch
apparently has a huge
impact on the area this is probably the
first large-scale destruction event of
the trailer here we see the new conquest
mode the reason
so many players are fighting in this
area is that conquest has been changed
it's now broken up into sectors that
have several objectives like a town to
take a sector one team needs to capture
multiple objectives which means players
won't be so spread out over the map like
in classic conquest
jump to hourglass dubai where the city
sinking into the desert and experiencing
extreme weather events like sandstorms
the map features a sinking stadium and
lots of abandoned vehicles
just have to say that honestly the neon
buildings in the sand look kind of
freaking amazing visually
very blade runner far in the background
you can see a sector objective blowing
up
here we see our first chopper fight it's
a good call choppers are a lot of fun in
cities in battlefield
it really helps them dodge around and
not get shot down so quickly
one appears to be a scout helicopter and
the other russian ka 50 black shark
on the roof we see maria the specialist
most closely resembling a medic class in
previous battlefield games
she can revive players back to full
health or heal from afar anyone can
revive a downed player like in recent
titles but not to full health
finally this very nice scout pilot lines
up for a battlefield moment
dev said battlefield moment quite a few
times in our press conference
meaning they want to bring back the
spontaneous sandbox
as the chopper goes down you see some
external building destruction
but again we didn't see any full
building destruction and it doesn't seem
like it's in the game
so now it looks like we're back on the
south korean city map and have two
modern jets a joint strike fighter and a
russian su-34
duking it out in the clouds these winged
vortices are kind of interesting
maybe a game mechanic that lets players
visually track jets better the clouds
are also a good addition because it
would make it hard for ground soldiers
to easily spot and destroy jets
under the joint strike fighter it says
vmfat-501
which is from a current marine training
squadron that's either an easter egg or
the situation on earth has gotten so bad
that we're using training squadrons
so here as the jet hits max altitude the
engine starts to sputter and stall
which is way better than getting stuck
in the skybox like you could in previous
titles
and now that other battlefield moments
this one people have actually done
before
the pilot seems to be firing some kind
of recoilless rifle like the classic
gustav
back on the ground we see the medic
maria again and next to her is casper
the recon guy in a ghillie suit his
gadget is the recon drone
and then robot dog charges through the
frame again the joint strike fighter
here crashes because
it looks cool and again we see those
interesting wing vortices
in the background there are also
multiple helicopters in an osprey so it
looks like this map will have a lot of
air assets here's another one of the 10
specialists that we don't know about yet
he seems to have a jamming or emp type
backpack
again specialists have a specialized
gadget and a trait but they can carry
any weapon or piece of gear
big explosion showing off ground
deformation and we're back to our
wingsuit enthusiast just in time for the
first extreme weather event
a big old tornado tornadoes will wander
through this map in sporadic paths
picking up and tossing soldiers vehicles
and
anything in their path you can also just
avoid them now we're back at espinoza
the specialist who took a soldier's dog
tag earlier
we get a little bit more information
here the class seems to have some kind
of extra armor
and finally we have a sick race between
a future tuk-tuk and a tornado the
tornado wins but the guy that picked the
wing suit is very happy and the tuk-tuk
cracks a joke about it battlefield 2042
is out october 22nd with confirmed
upcoming alphas
really we just scratched the surface of
what we learned in our press conference
so make sure to let us know what you saw
on this trailer that we missed or maybe
we just didn't have time to get to
e3 is about to get into full swing so
head on over to gamespot's youtube page
and make sure you don't miss a thing
from our play for all live streams
alright thanks for watching
[Music]
right